there we go I didn't know there was a
thumbnail thing that you'd yeah you've
never done mobile actions yeah well
actually I'll earn it yeah I know you
how much you want darkwing duck in there
it's B feet or so oh man no one beefier
than darkwing duck hello welcome to the
mousetrap live livestream we have here
just to show you guys random box of some
table we have this looks like a classic
version of mousetrap I think I've had
this since I was like two yeah so if you
guys don't you guys don't know what
mousetrap is there's a box of supplies
for mousetrap and we're gonna we we
don't have the instructions work we
gotta build the mousetrap first and then
we got to remember how to play the game
so we have no idea how to do that so
let's get to it we start here I know we
build as we go yeah oh I always built it
hurt me to read because you normally
default to read excuse me do you know I
don't want blue only one as far away
from Christmas as you do possible oh
wait no didn't we need cheese how do you
get cheese I land on the eyes I take
I've never played mouse trap for real
I've only ever supposed to start with
cheese that's all I know
I've only ever ever built the trap and
then set the trap off that's the only
dude who out there knows how much cheese
we start with how much cheese do you
start mousetrap you guys are no help at
all however many times you smash that
like button that's how much cheese we
have one two buckle my shoe how many
likes the bed how many likes huh this
fourth that like button it's a very
underused joke that I think it's not
funny but it's underappreciated cuz I
was trying to like I forget what it was
oh yeah no it was when it was tweet out
some and I want I like I was like I'm
gonna respond to that with the anchorman
Who I am a gift
cuz she just tweeted a picture of the
broken window but there's no gif of that
moment with big ol whammy text like
there's nothing I like I was on Twitter
and I was like psycho
somebody make that somebody ten thousand
people what happy that gif out there
what I just realized how similar this
looks to Woodstock I don't think that's
from this game isn't it is really yeah
he hits something I'm pretty sure he's
from this game Oh some kind of copyright
infringement going back here alright so
we've got these something someone said
anything something about pretzels
pretzels don't have nothing to do with
this objective or del juego the
objective of play an objective of a
mousetrap
objection
rumba para toners trap the mouse's trap
for Mouse's s construe here is to
construct une extraño artifact o cig we
end o las instrucciones del plan de
construcción so extravagant artifact
according to the instructions of the
plan and construction something like
that okay y luego
athelas utilize our low para trap our
most ratones del otro otros jugadores
something about trapping the other
players rats yeah when you have a turn
the crank right okay right right right
right right
Sokka todos las partes del juego de la
caja assemble all the players in the
beginning of coloca el caballero sobre
una superficie lana the table for the
overarching plans something like that I
don't know something about the plan
sokka todos los partings
I pizzas de la trampa para ratones de
las pulses eeka lokka la sala de tour
delta is getting in words that honor the
only thing I know is that these spaces
have to do with building tally last two
two three four
yeah there's build two things okay all
right let's do this
cuando Lego Tudor know when it's your
turn dear al lado in wave a roll the
dice and move the red el número de
aspasius in the kado move it the number
of spaces indicated luego CJ loccent
Oksana's impress us in el espacio de on
de que el Raton something about the
instructions will indicate follow the
instructions on the spaces
that you rat lab rat lands on dos o mas
Tony's two or more rats pueden estar en
el mismo espacio a la vez we land on
that we built well I think all I did was
say roll the dice all I got to write so
each time we land on one of these we
build something okay roll to go see who
goes first have a tough time being that
all right here I think we start with
three cheese do we ever determine
there's eleven thousand likes now so we
get 11 thousand cheese's so smash smash
the cheese button there yeah this is
just cheese catastrophe guys if you like
cheese smash that cheese button alright
I got it oh I think that might have to
do a turning the crank to I don't know
wait yeah I know there's a build as you
go cuz it says build - alright here let
me look up the instruction s here we are
insert Alice lenguin task killer
here we go wait and we go come Quattro
jugadores in a game with four players
play this conspiracy case guys sobre una
spacio deconstructionist
trucks one two three four okay with four
players construct don't you dare I'm
doing it we have to in the game with
three players construct the sky so a two
players where this conspiracy III sobre
una espacio they constructs you on two
to three or two three four okay
Oh Dona I don't fully understand but
what this thing is if there's two
players playing we construct on any of
these spots yeah any if it's two two
three four now I don't know why it's
trying to figure out what was once oh oh
oh you're cheating with the the dirty
English version up we got a dirty
English speaker over here God if you
love Spanish smash it smash that like
button
[Laughter]
I've tried you build something right
okay I'm trying to figure out if there's
rules for what you build on each space
I'm assuming you build the trap right
I'm guessing wait wait wait wait the
numbers indicate how many players in the
game if you have if this you only built
if you have four three or two players
players you build if you have two or
three players ah so I'm just glad you
just build you just build you just build
build it we got it all right or dunno
dos tres Quatro you get the belt I get
to build do I have to build just
anything you can build anything I guess
I should start the crank where's the key
what is up my crank o'licious crunk owes
I think you're only supposed to like put
one thing yeah I'm just gonna put this
okay I kind of cheated and already built
this yeah that sounds like you okay
you trapped your cheese it's the hidden
cheese it's safe so nobody gets stealing
cheese dividend see I'm smart that I
turned this into monopoly so that I
don't have to suffer when I die this was
when I was a kid
yesterday my mom busted out a photo
album of stuff if you saw my I saw your
which Amy Amy texted me today was saying
like I can't I can't deal with those
pictures I think I'm honestly gonna die
not in a good way I'm pretty sure it was
in a very bad way
anyway if you saw those pictures and you
thought you were gonna die or vomit like
button hit wham it really good when I
saw the initial when I thought you had a
chopstick in your mouth how far was the
head size increasing like that that
popsicle stick barely the thing is like
you notice it cuz if you look at my ears
Ramona as a kid when I'm a full-fledged
adult my ears look like they're normal
size but when I'm a kid they look bit
that's just how much my head expand no
you should just say the popsicle sticks
just aren't what they used to be yeah
all right 5 1 2 3 4 5 I bill build that
[ __ ] monetize you put like three thing
I've got one thing no that's three
things I think you silly [ __ ] we all
know it's supposed to rotate sure they
could I got a prop this up on something
higher cuz I don't think we got boxes
somewhere where do we have it
smash that like button no you can't here
I am that like button
it's ours you can do it if you've
already hit the like button on the like
button just to give it greater emphasis
okay all right Oh told you I was getting
a box okay I think this will be better
then they can see yeah my chest real low
like well this didn't help at all if
anything this is much worse I think we
just have to be a little farther away
[Laughter]
oh I've got eaten by the fat cat I'm
back at the start
dammit if you think I've been cheating
smash shares are a little long I get a
piece of cheese see what I mean by
cheating bastard you think he's cheating
tell the world and smash that share
button before I build give me that crank
it's building taking that off of the
wrong spot
[Music]
it's in their housing in the wrong spot
in what world the world another in
reality in reality okay maybe your
reality but not mine for let's get this
guy why that guy
there you for okay I got a build again
all right it doesn't seem to be doing
what its kind of look at some kind of
randomly generated thing or is it just
like this is a mechanism by which or is
there like a number of cranks that you
gotta yank it or does it just keep going
and Perpetuum them oh no
just this turn crank I wanna fight let's
put this guy here cuz even work it's
supposed to kick that
yeah but how I don't understand this is
supposed to hit it oh now it makes sense
and the rubber band is supposed to go
awake oh oh it pulls it back it pulls it
back that's so smart Milton Milton mr.
Bradley supposed to be another part
that's like an anchor to get it to like
weighing around a wall or you know what
I'm this way it's supposed to be
something here I think you crank it this
way maybe this way because it definitely
goes like this
that's not right you stupid fool you
fool
I'll be back he's cheating is getting a
new rubber band because he can't handle
the truth that he's terrible at this
game all right
oh there's instructions of habit but oh
that would be important wait no huelga
esta pieza del posted they lose con el
zapato so well gah
the piece the lamppost with the shoe en
la parte de la en la parte del on terra
del posted something about the post are
no lttle on t zapato david is cancer
control senior day stop not yet not yet
you fool
I was testing no not yet you fool
alright so that works alright good
everything's stable my turn ha alright
[Music]
you're barely rolling you've rolled like
a for everything no no no no no I call
[ __ ] everyone's watching this
cheating god oh no no no you're going no
no no you're going like you're going
he's going yes there but at least I feel
better about it
Hey geez okay
now watch a real man roll move add four
spaces I plan that one two three four
bell d time all right this goes up here
I think it goes down here cuz the oh
you're right you're right you're right
you're right when you're right you're
right and you are right you're right
that is a right right right the other
fine it's fine it's fine it's fine I'm
on I don't get to do anything okay
that's fine that's good
i'ii vibe one two three four five
I build ya waves yeah that goes there
yeah what's this this is mo he jumps an
OD really oh yeah that's right okay you
should do a back for something or you
can make him whatever way you want okay
he's gonna do a back flip I guess all
right I'm catching up to you I guess
five
wait Oh is the objective to go around as
many times as you can
this guy can't go get as much cheese
yeah cuz once you get here you collect
cheese I'm here you can have a shot at
trapping ah so you keep going until
someone gets trapped I get it I
understand it where do you disassembling
the the mystery that is mousetrap okay
yep
Oh real roll three one two three okay
then like a real boy no not at all
don't even just stop don't even ha
what is it four four one two three four
almost got the Mad Dog okay we're close
to being built good that means we're
close to getting this game underway
fascinating what happens when you land
on cheese wheel all the cheese is mine I
don't think that's it that's the rule
wait isn't that like oh do you take two
pieces of cheese now and then you go to
the safe we just roll around it you got
to go there already
that's not fair dad Anthology no you
don't get all the cheese she's cheating
see this is what I meant by cheating
bastard I really cheated so hard I've
got right yeah it's pretty cheating you
know it's pretty cheating you deal with
whatever the hell you're dealing with
your own personal problems I'm gonna
roll two one two
you can only build one of those two okay
all right then one not like you didn't
build 17 bajillion things I always knew
what was going on I read the Spanish you
read that you read the spinaroonie who
even knows if the the English has like
correct grammar and I get to build two
things okay go for it
I think so see I told you wood stocks
not supposed to be there he goes
different think I'm pretty sure none
port is your way oh it's nice right okay
you know what starts there all right get
ready to get your I don't know where it
is you think I'm paying attention is six
one two three four five six
there's nothing no what star killed him
yeah I don't let the building all right
it all comes down to this the non roller
here with the real roller what is it -
was it - ah what I do
nice ask him do you build a flimsy table
example that if you knock it stuff moves
yeah I can do that too a sturdy table if
it's still out Oh could you oh really
oh I doubt that all right see how the
real role that felt real three that one
there's nobody there
well turn it these people are paying
first wait get a close-up the action oh
it's off its I didn't know okay all
right I am NOT responsible for this now
that's hardly in there either
so yeah I'm gonna finish getting over it
oh all right go back to your spot you
have to wait hang on this supposed to be
[Music]
when the ball hits it it knocks it it
goes it goes like underneath it it works
somehow okay you know all right for all
right I'm gonna slide turn this a little
bit so it's easier for you to reach over
what if I don't want to so they can see
yeah yeah and now you can't butter win
some lose some and I better not lose
some I get damn it - piece of the cheese
damn it we're good friends and although
I wasn't saying that to you who are you
saying you want the audience to choose
me
everyone alert any drama channel in the
system star scarce Tyler wants his fans
to cheese what it what what would you
consider is cheesy oh I'm not gonna talk
about gross for one now oh my god you
neither all waters like it well lose one
I know cuz I lose all my
cheese if I get trapped I die well then
what's the point of even collecting
cheese it's like it's well if it's if
it's two player I guess the cheese is
worthless
it's just who gets trapped but let's go
with Auto 100 are in Jesus please post
it for now I need a three alright Jesus
do not give about three you're back
there okay I just want to be sure I need
a one these are reputable accidental
traffic doesn't work no I want to say
that was also a very piss-poor role I
wanna I want a compilation of all the
brothers just roll I don't even think
they're turning like I want a
slow-motion replay coming out of his
engine like the dice he's got a very
like if he was in Vegas he would be
kicked out by now for one of these days
I'll get cheese I got blue cheese give
it now you said it no I'm talking to the
game - cheese me
you want your face that's not what I did
that is a are you were like I said you I
was like to me and then you were like I
said Oh doc you to your fans
no oh
[Laughter]
you can go back show me that incident
for two on the safe spit out you're out
okay no oh that's okay five I heard you
have for six good roll there
fourth row in the box that would be
really smart of us Wow five
you got cheese move ahead one spot no
wait you're right damn it I scoop it I
get to turn the crank now that it does
anything um you can't kick them for four
hmm five Oh No give me one give me one
ha it's tip sprinkles for you [ __ ] damn
it give me one give me one nah eat tit
balls
hey four hello we're not friends get out
of here no yeah but so far mr. Magnus
for good following me I'm not where you
are shut up
- quit following me I can't smell any
more got you now I know your weakness
Gracie who knew who knew mass trap was
such a high stakes game who knew it
would work
I'm gonna put real money on this [ __ ]
yeah okay put in the bucket put in the
bucket
whoever wins twenty bucks now you have
to put in - honey my walls not on me all
right well you owe me three no come on
daddy needs a new 20 build one damn it
ha ha come on I'm never gonna forget
that Tyler just call themself daddy
I get cheese cheese for me I'll take
cheese over love anything do one [ __ ]
give me one give me one - damn it - jeez
nah forget more cheese bar nope that's I
get cheese my cheese my cheese for your
crankin for your cranking bore no yes
okay all right please please movie in a
1 or a 7 more for the more for the fact
that I just want this game to be over
now I just need two more ones watch this
tit ball man for six I'm still there
five three three no she's
Oh five crank but no good six five do no
five one do damage five well I know it's
meaningless but no I'm getting fat as a
mouse I'm assuming that the game will
end if we manage to get all the cheese
without trapping each other I guess six
one oh yes
okay please five oh I get cheese no no
no cheese there's only three Pete
there's four pieces and she's left for
right now it always comes down to a one
okay 103 all right three it is okay
that's good
I've been practicing on a shake weight
but what is it six come on haha for that
wasn't my roll five oh no damn it I got
cheese though it was a four I'm six
okay this two three there's three
there's another one oh there's three
pieces of cheese left the tiebreaker I
get to turn the crank no oh it's gonna
fail cuz you your head yes five oh I get
cheese
no yes I get the dang it come on damn it
one two cheese I get one cheese all
right so I'm not stopping until one of
us gets next damn it one oh come on
sighs all right six Lester all I gotta
do is gonna send it work three six
Jackman for now yes ah no cheese left
one useless for three I'm on there what
piece of you wait damn it
aha my chance one damn it do I want to
die or thanks I'm good
five
if you were here there's a five six stop
stop six one six three all right I'm
gonna add a twist into it
why we can choose whose mouths we move
now we come all this way we've come all
this way these lovely people have been
watching all this way for this mouse to
be gone by legitimate rules
international relation of mousetrap for
three have to stick by our morals or
encode a code mouse code Mouse code of
ethics say we live by the mouse we die
by the mouse one and we're gonna die by
this mouse for six
for boy and boy this is the longest game
ever won no all right you son of a [ __ ]
for all the fans you forced to choose
you for me after you listen to you say
the word daddy I never spent that what
you said daddy needs a new pair of shoes
you gotta fail it's gonna fail it's
gonna fail you don't know that
everything make sure everything's in its
place that crank is obviously out of
regulation this is firmly placed I'm
holding all these pieces this needs to
be firmly forward this needs to be
firmly in there all right everything's
regulation there's no cheating happening
right like it looks good all right that
was not it was not in regulation
planning it does it it was not in
regulation play it was not in position
that should about you it was not in you
were doing the inspection failed
inspector cheating cheater send them
that should have had Hey mine should
have had you would I had you know you
did you failed the kick everything was
in place that was not that probably
wasn't in place when I did it you know
yeah yeah you know I'd like to believe
that Santa isn't wrong about his naughty
list did you get call no well you're
getting it next year three thanks I'm
not getting cold now if you get me in
there then it's gonna be all regulation
now you're gonna get it for
six-six ah stop it I like the smell of
the cheese wheel okay o Lord of
mousetrap or high above God Bradley
himself Milton if you can hear me [ __ ]
you
six dos DOS don't you start switching to
Spanish five four
no all right nope I took back what I
said but I still think your mother is a
[ __ ] now that doesn't mean that she
didn't provide for you there's a very
hard profession to make sure that you go
to college to invent it board game
school and I appreciate that but still I
paid her okay all right you inspector
Hornung needs to be regulation that's in
its place these in flipping space this
is good okay
I think you won on the cheese front I'm
just glad it's all right thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
enjoyed this remember to and also that
bell ring that bell like a ding-dong
mousetrap all right it's like 10 degrees
outside now I'm sweating I'm sweating
all right have a good day everybody
we're out here see ya bye go subscribe
do Apocalypto on Twitch bye